ap bio uh is now available on peacock
the third season that many fans thought
would never happen
after was canceled after two seasons on
nbc the third season of ap
bio premieres today right here on this
streaming service on peacock and here to
celebrate that a little peacock festival
uh here on the rich eisen show glenn
howerton how are you glenn
hey i'm good can you hear me i can hear
you can you hear me sir
yeah i just you know technology these
days most of the time when i try to do
something it just absolutely fails
so i'm glad you can hear me well i'm
glad uh you can be heard i'm glad you
could be seen
on peacock we we love the streaming
service and uh you know and
the fact that uh peacock exists so ap
bio has a third season and hopefully
many more congratulations on that thanks
man yeah no it makes me very happy i
our audience right from the beginning
felt like more of a streaming audience
uh it's a slightly
excuse a little bit younger and uh you
know the show
the show was was originally streaming on
hulu and it was doing really really well
on a hulu
uh much better on hulu than it ever did
on nbc so yeah i'm excited that uh
people are gonna we're gonna be able to
give people a third season it's great
it's a great season so um how close are
you to the character you play
uh on this uh on the show glenn is there
any at
all um i'm grumpy okay i'm grumpy like
him not right now though
not right not right now though i did not
get a grumpy glenn howerton
in this phone call no you you're not
you're not getting grumpy glenn howerton
grumpy glenn howerton is usually right
when i wake up
uh and grumpy glenn howerton usually
hits around 2 30 in the afternoon after
lunch
uh that's that's when grumpy glenn
howerton is is at his worst
okay but that's that's your only uh
comparison
to the disgraced harvard philosophy
scholar jack griffin
yeah that's kind of it i mean i i'd say
that uh
you know i i think i i think i must
probably have some narcissistic
tendencies
uh in me because i feel this
overwhelming uh urge to play
narcissistic characters and i
feel like in some ways it might be me
uh i don't know exorcizing my own uh
my own uh demons or or something that
that i'm afraid of yes
like it's almost like i'm afraid of
being narcissistic so i have to make fun
of it
well there's one thing that you and my
and your your character
and me uh we have in common is i like
wearing cardigans sometimes you know
again
the shows just started launching on
peacock it launched in the middle of
august it's not appropriate to wear it
yet but
on occasion i will rock a cardigan uh on
this i broadcast
i'm the same way and now i feel like uh
you know
i've got a closet full of cardigans and
i feel like now i i'm not sure if i can
wear them anymore because people are
going to be like oh he's dressed like
his character right so
it's kind of so it's it's a mixed bag i
mean i
like i like that i get to wear it as a
character but it's kind of ruined it for
me as a
as a human being we've got glenn
howerton here on the rich eisen show
uh also uh known for being uh dennis
reynolds and always sunny in
philadelphia we had danny devito on last
week what was it like working with him
uh danny's the best man he's he's just
he's just great i mean he really is
not entirely unlike sort of the the
personality that you expect him to be
um you know he's like uh he's a he's a
generally happy guy
by the way he's a little grumpy
sometimes
well i think we might have gotten him
post trampolining that day he was in a
good mood
oh okay good good did you say post
trampolining yes he's a trampoliner
he trampolines that's funny he mentioned
that to me too and i i said
uh you know i said that's great it's
supposedly it's really good for
circulation and that's what i said yeah
and it gets your
i don't know what is it your your your
glands it gets your glands moving
it's good for your immune system by the
way now i think this is turning into ap
bio right now glenn
we're talking i did not expect to talk
about glandular reaction to blood
circulation but that's what it sounds
like
no he's the best man he's he's an
awesome awesome
awesome guy and he's been very cool
since the very beginning i mean one of
the coolest things he said to us i mean
because we were
you know nobody's when the show started
and when he came on in the second season
he made it very clear to us from the
very beginning he's like i i don't want
to
come in and i don't want to change the
show i don't want to become the lead of
the show i don't want to take over i
don't want to be the
800 pound gorilla on the show he was
like i just want to be
a part of this cast i just want to i
want to be a part of it i don't expect
to be bigger
you know what i mean and he so right
from the beginning he
he just made it very clear he's like it
was almost like his humble way of saying
i know i'm a massive massive star
but i don't want you to think that i
think of myself that way you know what i
mean
sure i hear you glenn howerton here on
the rich eisen show and also you were on
fargo right won a a season of fargo uh
several years ago i was yeah yeah i got
to do the first season of fargo um
yeah that was really cool i mean i so uh
that was obviously an fx
show and um
you know the the uh the president of fx
or the
the guy who runs fx john landgraf um he
he you know i've known him for years at
that point and uh you know he knew that
that my background wasn't really in
comedy my background was actually mostly
in drama
before i started doing sunny um and he
was like yeah we should have you in one
of our dramas
one day and i was like yeah it'd be
great um and he just called me up one
day and said hey we're doing fargo
and honestly my first reaction was okay
well that's one of my favorite movies of
all time
i don't know if it's a good idea to make
a show of that right
um you know i but i was like hey you
guys are smart i don't think you would
do it if it wasn't working so
uh you know they sent me a couple
scripts and it just
i mean noah holly the guy who who show
runs that show
um and created the show version uh
is just like one of the best
writers i've ever i've ever read i mean
the scripts were so good that i was
almost worried that they weren't going
to be able to make the show that good
um but uh yeah so i did i did like maybe
i don't know half the episodes in
in the first season it was it was
awesome yeah we had one of our friends
of of our program is colin
hanks who was tremendous in it he was uh
nominated for his role and billy bob's
been here too it's just been amazing
here i mean
you've been in a ton of great stuff and
the fact that uh a show that
uh appeared to be no longer gets revived
on peacock
is something that we can you know uh
appreciate
and uh this is pretty cool man for the
fans of this show who helped
save your program this is a gift when
these things happen in television
it really is and i i have to say like
i'm super stoked
that when i turn on peacock and i look
at the selection
of things that they have it makes it
almost makes me feel like i'm on an even
cooler show
than i thought i was because everything
on there is so good
uh i mean it's such a it's a really
strong service like
you know i mean with so many services
that are out there it was kind of like
oh god do we need another service and
now we're just going to be on this other
service and is anybody going to care
and i feel like they're kind of killing
it over there i mean
they've just got really cool stuff so i
feel like i'm in good company
you are i mean this show's on it glenn i
mean yeah exactly i mean i was going to
say
there's an in rich and eisen so i'm i'm
happy to say
um you know this is kind of about us too
you know what i mean
it's absolutely absolutely about you is
this there's also an eye in juilliard um
so how many fantasy football leagues are
in juilliard
are there any are there any juilliard
fantasy football leagues that i'm
unaware of
um you know you'd be surprised i i i
will say you would be surprised at the
number
of i thought i was going to go to acting
school
and everyone was going to just be really
artsy fartsy and
you know super actory and you know i
mean i i love all that stuff but but i'm
also
i don't know i'm into a lot of other
things too and and i was surprised at
how many sports fans there were i mean
they're just sports fans everywhere so
okay yeah no i mean uh
i think you people might have a a
certain thing in their mind about
the type of person that goes to
juilliard but um
you know i i found it to be fairly well
rounded
did man and hello go to juilliard is it
what you just said to me chris brockman
joe manganiello did
uh no actually joe uh and i just did a
movie with joe actually which is
coming out in december i think um there
we go uh joe's a great guy i love that
guy
um it does a great i don't know if
you've heard his uh schwarzenegger
impersonation but it's
incredible he said is it does he just
take his shirt off or
is that a schwarzenegger impersonation
or he actually sounds like arnie
no he actually no yeah he actually said
he actually sounds like he's one of
those
ones where he like i can do it too but
mine just sounds like you know a bad
like characterization he he really
sounds exactly like him i got to do it
the next
um but uh but no joe joe actually went
to carnegie mellon
ah okay another prestigious another
prestigious institution of
of arts um well look man congrats on uh
on the peacock third season uh it's a
hilarious show congratulations on that
pat and oswald is as funny as they come
paula pell i mean it's a great cast man
so congratulations on all that
i appreciate it yeah thank you thanks
for calling we'll we'll get you back on
what yes and i just tell everybo let
everybody know that it premieres tonight
yes indeed you could start streaming it
uh start streaming and you can stream
seasons one and two now but
i think the premiere of season three i
think it's tonight maybe it's on now
it might be on now
i haven't checked it might be already
well i mean as soon as as soon as this
show's over in 28 minutes you can get
off the nbc sports on peacock standalone
channel that this show is on every
single day and then go check out the
third season of ap bio that peacock made
happen how does that sound all right
wait 28 minutes 20
right 27 minutes now i appreciate that
thanks for the call glenn you take care
brother
all right good talking to you guys you
got it that's glenn howerton ap
bio it premieres today right now on
peacock
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here